BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
SUSANNAH RAUB: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
RETO MEIER: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY: This is primarily
a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
ERIC: All right.
Hello and welcome to Apps
Script Office Hours.
I'm Eric.
ARUN: I'm Arun.
ERIC: All right, and we're
back again this week.
This is our weekly broadcast
where we kind of give you an
update on what's new in Google
Apps Script and answer
questions from you guys.
If you're watching it on
YouTube, you can also join the
Hangout via the Google
Developers Live event page and
join in and ask us questions.
Or if you're a little shy or you
don't have a web cam, you
can ask those questions on the
Google Moderator that's
embedded right under
the event.
All right.
So how's it going, Arun?
What do we got for today?
ARUN: Well, this is the first
Hangout where I'm actually
speaking, so that's exciting.
Uh, I think the last time
I did with Jan, I
didn't say a word.
ERIC: A silent partner?
ARUN: That's right.
ERIC: Yeah.
ARUN: So this is my fourth
week here with the Dev
Relation team here
in New York.
I'm working specifically on Apps
Script with Eric, Kalyan,
Ikai, and Jan.
Very excited to be
on the team.
And have a lot of great
things going on.
Coming up to speed on the
product, getting to know the
community, so yeah, excited
to be on the team.
ERIC: Yeah, it's been
great to have you.
Actually, you have already
been the public
face of this team.
ARUN: That's right.
So I was over in DC on Friday
at the DevFest there.
It was actually quite
an exciting event.
It was an all day event.
It was actually combined with
the Startup DC event as well.
So we had over 150, almost
200 folks come in.
Don Dodge from Google
keynoted.
And then there were a few
other Googlers there
presenting as well.
And I was there representing
Apps Script and gave about a
45 minute talk along with a
gentleman from Unisys, Steve
Cousin, who's a VP of
technology there.
So I was actually pretty
well received.
DC has a very interesting mix
of folks with folks in the
nonprofit area, folks in
government, consulting services.
It's a good mix of technologists
there with a lot
of good questions.
And not a lot of them had used
Apps Script before, so it was
good for them to kind of
see and ask a lot of
questions as well.
ERIC: Yeah, that's great.
Is there a bit of a different
vibe there in the community
compared to the West Coast
or here in New York?
ARUN: Definitely
from New York.
I think I haven't been to the
West Coast that often.
Specifically not for technology
travel based for
technology events.
But in New York, I feel like
folks are potentially using
Google Apps at work.
Folks are definitely using Gmail
and other things for
personal use in DC.
It was for the first time I
think they had seen a live
Apps Script demo.
ERIC: Oh wow.
ARUN: So that was exciting
to deliver that.
ERIC: That is great.
ARUN: And the power and the
message of Apps Script kind of
came through, right.
JavaScript--
pure JavaScript--
extended with the Google APIs,
running in the cloud, and you
code it in the browser.
You don't have to install an
Eclipse plug-in, or SDK, or
anything like that.
So it's actually
quite powerful.
And I got through.
ERIC: Yeah, that's cool.
I know we're actually gaining a
lot of Google Apps customers
in different governments
around the country.
So I can definitely see how
being involved in the DC
community, having Apps Scripts
kind of fits in nicely with
people who are already on
the Apps infrastructure.
ARUN: That's right.
That's right.
Yeah.
So it was exciting.
Interesting questions
came up as well.
So as pretty frequent Apps
Scripters, we kind of forget
about some of the tendencies of
developers that come from
other platforms, right.
So an interesting question that
came up was, how does
source control work?
I'm used to Subversion.
I'm used to Git.
So Apps Script actually has a
built-in basic but pretty
functional source
control system.
Right, so you can
version things.
You can deploy different
versions for a web app or a
library, for instance.
So you can actually be working
on a development instance,
test that out, and then be able
to roll back or publish
the latest version.
So we kind of talk
through that.
You can actually share the
project with multiple
collaborators as well.
So it's got some built-in
capabilities.
And obviously it's
on the cloud.
So you don't have to worry
about copying it down and
backing it up and things
like that.
So walking through
things like that.
We obviously had to clarify
when does App Engine make
sense, and when does Apps
Script make sense.
It has the unfortunate thing
that they both start
with the word Apps.
And I actually followed an
event on App Engine, so
there's an extra confusion.
But what I think really made
sense to folks is if you're
using any of Google's products
as an underlying data source
or service like Maps, or
Translate, or Finance, or
tapping contacts, or
spreadsheets, or Gmail,
definitely App Engine
makes sense--
I'm sorry, Apps Script
makes sense.
App Engine gives you a lot more
bare metal control when
that makes sense and you needed
a local IDE with the
right tooling and things
like that.
So there's a balance there,
but kind of walk people
through that.
ERIC: Definitely seems like
maybe it has a little bit to
do with how intense your
application is.
If you need to do a highly
customized, highly performance
based activity, App Engine
might be a better source.
But if you've just gotta plug
some data from here to there--
which I feel like a lot of
programming is, right?
I got this.
I need to move it over here.
I need to take one and
turn it into ten.
Those kind of basic operations
is a great strong point for
Apps Script.
ARUN: Yeah, for sure.
So that resonated pretty well.
ERIC: That's cool.
ARUN: Yeah.
ERIC: That sounds like
a great time.
We're glad to have you on
the team representing.
ARUN: No, it's great
to be on the team.
ERIC: Speaking of user events,
we have another
Hackathon coming up.
ARUN: That's right.
November 13, in Los Angeles.
Ikai, myself, I'm sure a few
other folks from the team,
including the engineers on the
product will be there.
So if you're in the LA area,
definitely come out there.
We would love to
see your ideas.
Have access to the actual folks
that work on the product.
You can log issues.
But very rarely do
you get access
to the actual engineers.
So if you're on the West
Coast, come on
down, November 13.
ERIC: Yeah, definitely
a rare treat.
We just did the one previously
in Austin.
Had a lot of great people come
out, kind of spanning the
range of experience.
And more people in business,
more people that are
developers.
And it was really great just
to set aside time.
Apps Script is one of these
things that everybody I kind
of follow on social networks,
they're always like, I gotta
spend a weekend and
just learn this.
And they probably--
your weekends fill
up pretty fast.
And Apps Script, I'm sure,
loses out to the beach or
spending time with family.
ARUN: Especially if you're
in California.
ERIC: Yeah, exactly.
So I think it's great to
have these hackathons.
It's a good excuse to take the
time, to learn this thing
you've been meaning to learn,
and actually apply it.
And to have us there kind of
giving instruction, answering
questions, so much easier to get
started than if you were
just alone with some
documentation.
And we try and make
the documentation
as good as we are.
But there's nothing
like coming out.
ARUN: Yep, absolutely.
And I'm sure there'll
be some prizes.
If Ikai is involved, I'm sure
he'll bring some schwag.
So yeah, you should be there.
ERIC: That's great.
ARUN: Excellent.
Do you want to do the
release notes?
ERIC: Yeah, so our release
notes this
week are pretty simple.
We just had one bug fix.
It was an issue where some
files couldn't be copied.
The docs list dot copy
method didn't work.
I believe it was on
presentations and a couple
other file types.
So yeah, that's one
that we addressed.
It's fixed.
It's out there.
But yeah, this release notes
page, if you haven't been
following it, it's on
our documentation.
It's a great way to stay abreast
of kind of when new
features are added to
Apps Script and when
bug fixes are made.
Unlike, I guess, other kind of
development platforms or
environments, we don't have
like hard release numbers,
like you need to upgrade
from 2.0 to 3.0.
We just roll out features and
fixes kind of on a rolling
basis, usually like one
per week or so.
So this is where you tune it
and find out what's new.
ARUN: Yeah, that's actually one
of the things that convene
here on the team.
That's everything from the
editor where you write the
code, to the API's where you use
it to write against your
code, the platform on top of
which the actual app runs,
everything's on the cloud.
In some ways, it's kind of
set it and forget it.
And then I've already
experienced this where I'll
come back to a project a week
later and things look a little
bit prettier, faster.
And it's a great feeling.
It's a true feeling, it's
a great feeling.
ERIC: Yeah, it's nice to take
some of that burden off, like
staying on top of the releases
and deprecations.
ARUN: Right.
And I used to use a
lot of Eclipse and
Visual Studio before.
And when updates come out, I'm
always deciding whether it's
the right time to upgrade.
Am I going to break something?
So we do a lot of that internal
testing to ensure
that everything is maintained
compatibility wise, and things
only get better, and faster,
and more stable.
ERIC: Here, here.
ARUN: Awesome.
ERIC: Cool, let's see if there's
anybody who's in the
live hangout, just in case we
have any immediate questions.
Looks like it's just us.
ARUN: All right.
ERIC: That's all right.
Well, we have some questions
here on our moderator page.
So let's see what we
got going there.
ARUN: All right.
So the first one, I think a
couple folks have kind of
brought this up recently.
It's a link to a question
in Stack Overflow.
I'll actually go there.
I think it's around--
let me blow this up
a little bit--
so it's around large code files
that when you're editing
it, you know, sometimes when it
goes up to 18,000, 20,000
lines of code, the
UI freezes up.
Potentially this gentleman
here has figured out that
maybe there's a megabyte
limit for script size.
So it's something that a couple
folks have reported.
I've actually put a link in
there for an issue tracker
link where I think people had
reported this earlier in the
spring and summer.
Seems a little sporadic
from what I've heard.
I'm not sure if--
ERIC: Yeah, I mean, first
of all, that's
a serious app script.
20 lines, [INAUDIBLE]
Apps Script, that is
a serious user.
Thank you for using Apps Script
at this level and we
definitely want to make
sure it works for you.
And so yeah, I have heard other
reports in the past that
people saying that as your code
size grows, the editor
gets more sluggish.
I think it has to do with the
way we're sending your code to
and from the server.
But that's definitely something
we should address,
because we want to make
these kind of complex
applications possible.
But yeah, and to the second
point that you put there,
really, if you're this user,
and you found this problem,
which is obviously a bug, it's
probably not something you're
doing wrong.
It's probably not something
our average
user can help with.
It's probably going to save time
to head straight to the
issue tracker.
Just open a bug report
with us.
This is the kind of thing where
on Stack Overflow, you
know, the community is going to
see it, but probably not be
able to solve your problem
as easily.
ARUN: Right.
ERIC: So do open an issue
tracker item.
And you can do both, because
maybe some users have found a
workaround, and you want
to ask for workarounds.
But as far as getting it fixed,
the issue tracker is
where you're going to need
to come to kind of--
ARUN: And definitely
star issues there.
It helps us see which ones are
popular and most demanded by
our community.
So definitely we'll
take a look at it.
It may also have to do with--
you know, we do a lot of
things around autosaves.
We do a lot of things
to help you.
But in some cases, that
might trip us up.
ERIC: And I think something that
he had mentioned in the
comments there was about
using libraries.
We do have library support in
Apps Script that allows you to
somewhat more componentize
your code.
You know, have a reusable
library that you import, but
isn't actually in the
editor at that time.
Now, obviously, if you have your
code written in a way, it
could be hard to disentangle
it into separate libraries.
But that can be way that if from
the start, if you kind of
build in a more modular
approach, like, OK, I'm going
to put all of my Gmail
logic into this file.
And maybe later, you could
bundle that up into a library
that then makes it easier to
create these large projects.
And even better, later on when
you're creating a new project,
you could bring in all that
same functionality without
having to do a big copy
paste or a rewrite.
So libraries may help
in the short term.
But obviously long term, you
should look for ways to make
sure that you're not crashing
your editor.
ARUN: Another thing that I've
noticed when files get real
long is a lot of static data.
So seed data, or sample
data, or other sort
of helper test data.
If possible, move it into a
spreadsheet, or ScriptDb, or
something along those lines
so that the number of
characters goes down.
It's unlikely that there's 18
kilobytes, 18 K lines of
logic, but we'll see.
We'll take a look at this one
and ping our engineering team
and see what we can find.
The good thing is a lot of these
things do result in logs
on our side that we can
see any spikes or
any abnormal behavior.
So hopefully we can
pin it down.
ERIC: All right, great.
And one of the things, that
when you do file an issue
tracker item like this, as you
mentioned, we have these
internal logs.
And really, in order for us to
kind of pinpoint your specific
problem, it helps if you include
in your bug report,
what the project key is for
that script project.
So that's something that you
could find under, I think it's
File, Project Properties, or
Project Settings menu.
And in there, it will list
your project key.
And that just helps us in our
logs, kind of target right in
on what the error message it.
ARUN: Great.
The next one is from
Ontario, Canada.
This one is, "want to have
access to geolocation data
collected either through UiApp
or HTML service form." So any
plans for this?
And then, also a link to the
same request in Stack
Overflow, which I think points
to an issue or enhancement
request in issue tracker.
So this one, actually the past
nine years, I was working at a
mobile software company.
So geolocation is very near
and dear to my heart.
So I'm very interested
in this one as well.
ERIC: Yeah, by the this, does he
mean the kind of automatic
where your browser, once you
approve a certain website,
will send geolocation data?
ARUN: That's right.
Yeah, so this is part of the
HTML5 spec that a lot of folks
are now starting to use which
is the navigator dot
geolocation, and in most
browsers, I think it's a
little pop up that says it's
asking for your location.
You approve it.
And the browser can get-- if
the hardware supports it--
get a geoposition based
on the callback.
ERIC: Gotcha.
Yeah, so I think one of the
limitations around this today
is that the two different ways
we have of presenting a UI or
a web page to the user is the
UiApp and the HTML service.
Both of those today are
on HTML4 standard.
So they're not on HTML5
at the moment.
So if you're using some of
these more advanced HTML5
APIs, they're probably
not going to be
supported right now.
But obviously HTML5 is a big--
we love it here at Google.
So we're looking on how to get
that enabled for these two
services, probably the HTML
service directly.
But until then, if you're trying
to use some of these
newer more exotic APIs,
it might not be there.
ARUN: Right.
And I think that [INAUDIBLE], I
think, pointed out that this
is probably Caja.
That's the culprit here, at
least for the HTML service.
And he's absolutely right.
And I wouldn't call it a
culprit, because Caja helps us
quite a bit.
And then for the folks that
don't know, Caja is basically
the pre-processing engine before
anything HTML services
spit out to the browser.
And that's to sanitize the code
so that there's nothing
malicious, even unintentionally,
that gets pulled in.
So when you reference a third
party JavaScript library, even
though you may have the best of
intentions, that JavaScript
library may have other
dependencies, which may bring
in cookies, things that
we may not want on the
script.google.com domain, which
is where your code is
served out of.
Obviously, that's a great
benefit from Caja.
But there are some limitations
that we have to deal with.
And we're trying to find
the right way to go
forward with that.
ERIC: Yeah, that's
a great point.
Sometimes we blame the Caja
for certain things.
But it gives us so much that
it's a give and take.
ARUN: All right.
Here's a good one. "Is there any
way to add, modify, delete
shared contacts on a Google Apps
domain via Apps Script?
What about other administration
of Google
Apps?"
ERIC: Yeah, so we do have some
domain level services in our
documentation.
Actually, I think we can
browse through them.
ARUN: Yeah, so let me actually
pull that up.
ERIC: So if it's under default
services and then the domain
subcategory.
You can see we have one there
called user manager.
I think user manager should
allow for some of this.
But I don't know the
exact details.
Let's find out.
ARUN: Yeah, this is actually
one of the interesting use
cases for Apps Script is for
large enterprises and service
integrators that deploy many
domains or automate a lot of
the provisioning aspect
of things.
This is a great way for them to
create users from a legacy
LDAP system or spreadsheet,
move people around.
So it's actually been
quite powerful.
So I've seen some really
cool use cases here.
So I think this gentleman here
is asking about being able
to-- let me go back
and look at this.
ERIC: I think it was a
deleted user, right?
ARUN: Right, so being able
to add, modify, or
delete shared contacts.
ERIC: Oh, well actually, I
guess that's different.
OK.
You're right.
My bad.
So this domain users is
actually adding a
user to your domain.
But there's a different thing
in the domain, which is in
your Gmail contacts.
There's your local contacts.
And then there's the
shared contacts.
And that's a bit different.
I don't know if we support
the shared contacts.
I believe I looked into
it in the past
and it wasn't supported.
That these contact groups that
we have available in this
contacts app are only
your local contacts.
But that's something we
can double check on.
And I think for questions like
this, to go to Stack Overflow
is great, because you ask
us here on the spot,
we're like uh-- uh--
Right now, this is a thing we
can look up and get back to
you on, too.
ARUN: Great.
Yeah, definitely post this
on Stack Overflow.
And if it's already there,
we'll go find it.
The next one is from Holland.
"Will the setStyleName method
be activated in GAS as in
GWT?"
ERIC: So, we're getting
international here with our
questions, which is awesome.
So for the UiApp, we're
basically building on top of
the Google Web Toolkit
technologies.
Which do allow you to control
styles in a more complex way.
I think, though, there are
certain elements of the style
setting from Google
Web Toolkit we
don't have in UiApp.
I don't remember the exact
history behind it.
But if that method is not there
today, I'd probably say
it's not going to be
there tomorrow.
Again, I can talk to the
engineers again and see what
the reasoning was.
But in a lot of cases, I think
we decided we wanted UiApp to
mostly be a simple solution
for simple problems.
I think it mostly is that.
And if you're really looking for
more complex styling, more
complex behaviors, the new HTML5
service that we talked
about is really where you can
go to kind of just do
everything customized.
But for little incremental
features that maybe will make
UiApp a little easier
to use, it's
something we can talk about.
So yeah, file this in the issue
tracker as a feature
request if it's not there.
ARUN: All right.
Here's another one
from Canada.
Oh, where'd it go?
ERIC: I think it jumped
up there.
ARUN: Oh.
Someone just [INAUDIBLE]
it up.
So this one is a link to
Stack Overflow as well.
This one is specifically
around security.
I think security in a few terms,
I think, access to the
actual code, how siloed is the
ScriptDb instance itself?
And then, the hacking
aspect of things.
So this is all round
generalizing to "how secure is
a web app code and his
ScriptDb data?"
ERIC: So it looks like he talks
about a few different
parts there, right?
The code of the web app, the
data in the database, and
then, I guess, chances
of hacking.
So, we obviously take security
very seriously here at Google.
And we do a lot of things
to make sure that when
something's yours, and it's
private, it's not
accessible by others.
So the chance of someone
hacking it, I'd
say, is very low.
We prevent that explicitly.
And we look out for it.
Now, for the other two,
how about the
code and the ScriptDb?
There are some sharing models
built in that could maybe
affect this.
Now, for the actual code of
your web app, you can keep
that private.
There's no reason you have to
make the public to anybody.
When you publish as a web app,
they'll be able to see the
executed version of it.
ARUN: That's right.
ERIC: But not the
source itself.
ARUN: Yeah, think of that as if
you had written it in PHP,
or .NET, or Rails, it's
basically the rendered version
of your code and logic.
ERIC: Now, the only kind of
caveat to that is that when
you're using a library, even
when it's part of a web app
that's being served to a user,
today that library needs to be
public even to the user
using your web app.
So the code of the web itself
can stay private.
But any libraries it uses
need to be public.
Now, that said, you don't need
to necessarily broadcast where
this library is and how people
can see it's code.
But the code in a library does
need to be made public for
someone to use it.
So that's one thing
to keep in mind.
But in general, we do recommend
that you take
anything that's private, like
passwords or special
connection parameters--
don't put them in code, because
code can be viewed a
lot more easily than the project
properties, or the
script properties as
they're called.
So these script properties allow
you to store little key
value pairs of data that even
when someone has read only
access to your script, they
still can't see them.
Only the code is readable.
But the actual properties
aren't.
So that's really the best
place to put any sort of
information that you wouldn't
want even the guy who sits
next to you at work to see.
ARUN: That's right.
That's right.
It's fair.
It's sort of like a config file,
and [? IAMO ?] file, and
other environments.
It allows you to tuck away
name value pairs.
So that's good.
What about the data in
the ScriptDb itself?
What's the scope of it?
ERIC: Yeah, so the ScriptDb
is all scoped to
that particular script.
Every script gets a ScriptDb
when you create it.
And it can only be accessed
within that script.
So if somebody else has another
script, they won't be
able to poke in and get
into your ScriptDb.
Now, that said, in your web
app, it doesn't matter.
All users of your web app have
access to the same ScriptDb.
They don't get their
own ScriptDb's.
So if one user stores
his data--
if one user gives you his data
and you store it in ScriptDb,
and another user gives you his
data and you store it in
ScriptDb, they're going to
be side by side there.
So if you perhaps make a mistake
in your code, and when
you're showing a table of
records, you show records from
both users, when you
really should only
show that user's record.
You could potentially get
data out there that way.
But that's really due to more
of a logic or programming
mistake in your code than kind
of the underlying model.
ARUN: And that's a similar
problem with MySQL or any
other storage mechanism
that you may use.
ERIC: That's right.
ARUN: That makes
a lot of sense.
Great.
That's a really good question,
and I think there are already
some good answers on Stack
Overflow as well.
ERIC: Yeah, we have a great
community there that loves to
pitch in their answers.
ARUN: Great.
All right, so let's see--
ERIC: It looks like there's
a problem with
our hangout, maybe.
ARUN: That's interesting.
All right, well, we will try to
rectify that the next time.
ERIC: Yeah, I guess that makes
sense why nobody joined today.
ARUN: That's unfortunate.
Well hopefully you'll find the
replay of this still useful.
I think we went through a lot
of useful things today.
ERIC: Yeah, luckily
we had a ton of
questions on the moderator.
And sometimes it's great just
to even ask the questions of
the moderator, because then
you can give us a link to
Stack Overflow, how
to look things up.
So that's pretty cool.
ARUN: Great.
ERIC: So let's just refresh
that page one more time to
make sure we don't have any
last minute questions.
ARUN: Yep.
Let's see here.
OK, we talked about that.
Talked about that.
Let's see.
I think that's it.
ERIC: All right.
That's great.
All right, so I think we had
some great questions today.
And we'll be back next week.
We haven't scheduled it yet.
But we'll probably be back
in the morning next week.
But yeah, keep watch
on developers.googl
e.com/live/drive, where you'll
see all the Drive and Apps
Script office hours.
And then you can find out when
we're coming up next.
ARUN: Excellent.
Thank you.
ERIC: All right, thanks
everybody.
We'll see you next week.
ARUN: Bye bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]